vous avez un petit chauffage d'appoint
juste en dessous qui permet chauffer des
petits plaide éventuellement si vous
avez un petit peu froid manger une
fondue dans une télécabine c'est devenu
possible en touraine grâce au restaurant
la bodega et son partenaire glam sprint
car cet hiver le montbazon se transforme
en montagne ici un restaurant savoyarde
décoré en stations de ski pour la saison
froide l'occasion jusqu'au 9 avril de
retrouver l'ambiance des sommets sans
faire pleurer son porte-monnaie
la montagne à quelques kilomètres de
tours
à défaut
dans l'ambiance ce qui c'est la première
fois qu'on vient ici la cabine est très
très confortable on a le chauffage on a
les petits coussins
pour relancer l'activité du bar
restaurant il fallait planter le décor
deux télécabines un télésiège et même
une moto des neiges
coût de l'investissement 30000 euros
soit 10% du chiffre d'affaires du
restaurant un pari risqué mais couronnée
de succès pour le géant
l'idée c'était de partir sur une
opération un peu divers pour changer un
petit peu d habitude qu'on voit partout
d'en créer une autre station de ski
voile abritera la très satisfait les
lectures nous le rendent bien ça qu'on a
beaucoup de on a beaucoup de bons
retours par rapport à ça plus qu'on
imaginait donc on arrive à avoir des
clientèles de 40 50 km autour de nous
donc ça nous permet de faire deux à
trois fois plus de clients par rapport
aux années précédentes en moyenne donc
120 couverts le samedi soir contre
seulement une trentaine avant
l'opération un franc succès qui se fait
sentir sur le calendrier environ trois
semaines d'attentes pour déjeuner dans
un oeuf